Hello there! In this video, we will
explain why too many dimensions
can be both a blessing and a
curse when doing machine learning.
So, it’s Ms. Coffee Bean here with a video
about some important basics in Machine learning.
First we have to explain: What are dimensions
and why do we need them in Machine Learning?
The number of dimensions describes the
number of coordinates we have to give
in order to fully localize a point.
For example, we have one dimension if we only need
one coordinate to find the point,
like this point on this line.
For two dimensions, we already need
two numbers to localize one point.
Three dimensions are very normal
for us, because space around us
is three dimensional and to localize an
object, we have to specify three points.
But the spatial dimensionality in particular,
does not limit dimensionality in general:
Dimensions can be anything, especially
in machine learning problems.
For example, to characterize
a data point, like a rocket,
we might need a dimension
where we specify it’s speed.
We can specify the rocket’s
weight in a second dimension,
it’s height in a third dimension and so on…
In some Machine Learning contexts,
it is quite common to use the word
dimension as a synonym for feature.
And theoretically, nothing stops us to increase
the number of dimensions or features to infinity.
We take whatever we can to characterize
a point, because these features can be
then used by a machine learning algorithm
to differentiate points one from another.
But what do high dimensional
spaces bring with them?
A large number of dimensions can be a blessing.
Think about problems that are not linearly
separable in low dimensions, so cases in
which we can not just draw a line to separate
our data with, for example, linear regression.
But certain mappings to higher dimensions,
can make the data linearly
separable, so very easy to solve.
However helpful in these cases, many
dimensions can quickly become a curse.
To visualize: We have two points
A, and B in only one dimension.
To compute the distance between the two,
we just have to compute the difference
between their coordinates. Done.
In two dimensions, the distance
computations become a little more difficult,
since we now have more coordinates for our points.
And if we assume that the points
lie on the diagonal of a cube,
forming a 45 degree angle with both axes,
then the distance simplifies a little.
It becomes the difference between the
coordinates in one of the dimensions,
say x multiplied by the square root of two.
And two happens to be the
number of dimensions. Hmm….
We observe the same pattern in one dimension,
where the difference of the coordinates is
virtually multiplied by square root of one,
which is again our number of dimensions.
The same holds also for three
dimensions, where the distance
between diagonal corner points of the
cube scales with square root of three.
And here we generalize, without delivering
the proof now, that the distance between
such points A and B is proportional to the
square root of the number of dimensions D.
What does this mean? Well, it means
that in a high number of dimensions,
there is a lot of space to begin with, so
we have a lot of new places to put points
into, since the distance between them
is bigger with each added dimension.
When distances increase, it also means that
the overall volume of the space increases,
so that we need many more points to
sample the space with the same density.
For one dimension, it might be enough to sample
only two points, but in two dimensions one needs
4 points to fill a grid with the same interval
and already 8 points in three dimensions.
To be precise, with each dimension, we need
exponentially more points to populate the space
with the same density as in a lower space.
Oh no, what do we do?
High dimensional spaces are like a two-sided
coin On the one side, high dimensions
are a blessing for linear separability.
On the other side of the coin, there is a curse:
many dimensions increase the
overall volume of the space,
so points and machine learning optimizers can
get lost inside the void of high dimensionality.
So what do we do? There are ways to decrease
dimensionality. And in the next video, we will
explain how dimensionality reduction works!
Can’t wait!
Are you still here? Go and do not let the dark
side of dimensionality take over. See you, bye!